Please round of applause.
Welcome to the stage director
and star of a quiet place.
John Krasinski.
I'll use all the stairs.
Thank you. Hey everybody.
Hello.
What's up?
These are huge thing.
I know the time now I'm blinded,
but I know the time.
The last thing I ever saw was the time.
So, so many ways that that could tie
into what we're going to talk about.
It's the best way to tie it all in. Yeah,
no, it's hopefully, thanks so much guys.
That was great.
Appreciate it.
So this is really new ground,
uh,
Standard John Rhe creature feature,
pretty different.
Take on things that you've done in the
past. What do you mean talking about it?
That's the funniest movie of the year,
guys.
I don't know if you're going to love it,
but then also taking on the directorial
role, uh, cowriting creditors,
co-writer, but more really rewriting the
screenplay to get it to take place. Uh,
how was it for you to broach
this genre? It was, um,
it was really scary, but it was really,
uh, exciting too. I mean, for me, um,
it's, it's the weirdest thing. I actually,
nothing will ever top the office. Right?
So it's this thing that was the
first experience I ever had.
It gave me all this opportunity
and I just felt, if I'm honest,
I just felt like I needed to earn it
and I needed to deserve that amazing
opportunity.
So I tried to go out and do all these
new different things to push it because I
know all my friends that came up
with me would do the same thing.
That's really what it comes down
to. And so for me, it's just about,
and I'm so lucky to have this opportunity
to say this because some people,
most people can't,
but I just looked for the stuff
that really hits me and moves me.
And so it seems really
weird from that poster.
But this is truly a love letter to my
kids because this whole movie is about
parenting. And what would you do for
your kids to protect them? And again,
I know that poster does not say that,
but when you see the movie,
I read the original script by Beckon
Woods and the idea is so great. I was,
I have never been into horror ever.
Like I was so scared as a kid of horror
movies that I've never really watched a
lot of horror movies.
And so when I was sent the script,
I definitely thought there's no way I'm
doing this. And then I read the, uh,
the idea of a family that
has to remain quiet. Um,
and you have to figure out why
it was such a compelling idea.
And then when I started to read it,
it was just all about family.
It was about this,
these parents trying to do
everything they could for their kid.
And the truth is we had just had our
second daughter three weeks before I read
the script. Listen, I cry at
anything. It doesn't really,
not that much of a compliment
that I cried reading the script,
but I was a wide open,
you know,
vessel of emotion and tension and I was
actually living through what this family
goes through, not the
creatures part, but you know,
trying to keep your kids safe and alive
and are you a good enough person to be
her dad? Like all that stuff
is going through my head.
So when I did do the rewrite,
that's where I focused that I thought I
could actually be the perfect person to
do this because I was feeling
so emotionally connected.
Well and it's great that you think of it
that way and there are so clear on that
messaging because it does really feel
aside from all the creatures that are
around it is this sort
of coming of age drama.
There's this great father, daughter
dynamic, great father, son dynamic, uh,
saw the movie. Um, um,
how was it to sort of put the horror
and the creature stuff aside to really
focus on that and dig into,
hey work,
we're going to deal with some really
heavy issues but also the world around us.
It's crazy.
It's this thing. The truth
of the matter is, and um,
Greg Daniels who created the office,
I remember there was one
day where he said to me,
your job is not to deliver these lines.
Funny. Your job is to deliver these lines,
play the truth of the moment.
And the people think it's funny.
People think it's funny. And if people
think what you say to Pam is emotional,
then it's emotional, but it's
up to them. It's not up to you.
And that sounds like a tiny bit of advice,
but it actually changed my entire career
and certainly was the reason why I did
this. I mean, truly if he
had not given me that advice,
I wouldn't have done this movie because
if someone said go direct a horror movie,
I'd say, I don't know. I
don't know how to do that.
But what I did do is I reverse
engineered it exactly as he taught me,
which is your job is not to scare
people or make the movie scary. Your,
your job is to make a movie honestly and
tell a story that you really connect to
and you're confident with.
And if people get scared,
that's up to them and you realize he's
absolutely right because of the family
dynamic.
You actually are more scared in the
movie because you don't want anything to
happen to that family member.
So again, I mean truly, uh,
you know, I learned everything from the
office and certainly Greg Daniels advice.
There was the reason why I felt
confident enough to do it. That said,
I am also a super nerd when it
comes to this stuff. You know,
I remember my dad when we were little,
one of the best bits of advice
he ever gave me was, you know,
one of the most confidence things you
can say as a person is, I don't know.
And so diving into this,
I knew a lot of what I wanted to do
and I knew a lot of what I didn't know.
And so I had to go out there and
I had to a watch scary movies.
So if you look at my iTunes for the last
year, you'd think I have a problem. Um,
and I just watched all
the scary movies I could.
The first thing I realized
was how ignorant I've been
to not participate in this
genre world.
I mean,
some of the best movies I've seen in
the last few years are genre movies from
get out to the which to the
Baba Duke to let the right one.
I mean there's so many good movies.
So I just became such a huge fan and
took it all in and then creature design
just dove deep into that
world and it was just really,
really fun actually to stay. I love
stepping outside of my comfort zone.
I remember as a kid I wasn't
the best basketball player,
but there was like that,
that idea of like put me in and if
I screw up, never put me in again.
Um,
and that sort of how I feel about life,
I've taken on different genres
and tried different things,
but I'm fully confident with the fact
that if I do it wrong or I'm not good at
it, don't let me do that, please.
Well, I, I definitely think I did.
A lot of people saw the movie,
had the ability to see it.
The people who were crying,
the ones that you saw it last night.
One of the things when I saw you
don't really hide the monsters.
It's not like a jump scare kind of, you
know, some of that that takes place.
But really it's,
it's a masterful use of tension.
And I think back to like, uh,
like the concept of checkoffs gun,
there's so much great foreshadowing and
sort of like little glimpses and little
hidden things that then pay off
in such a big way. Uh, you know,
playing a, wearing multiple
hats, hymns, acting in it,
and also having written
it and directing it.
And did you find it difficult to embed
that stuff, navigate that stuff? Uh,
from both sides of the
glass? Uh, on the Lens?
Yeah. It's one of those things where
when you do this as a new experience,
you don't know how it
can go horribly wrong.
And so you just commit to
what you know. And so, I mean,
you're mentioning that
the, the gun idea, it's,
it's that thing of I just
knew what would scare me.
And I also knew that story wise,
what would be interesting to me.
And I thought that the conceit was so
brilliant that you have to just set it up
all along.
I also remember I wrote the script,
a promised land while ago that I wrote
with Matt Damon and we went to the
marketing department at focus features.
And first of all,
the guy scared the hell out of me
because he was like, I know everything.
I know what states you're popular in.
I know what states hate you.
You want to know that stuff? And
I was like, definitely not my, uh,
my ego cannot handle that.
But what I do want to know is what's
the biggest misconception, uh,
in your opinion of audiences?
And he said the biggest misconception
that the film industry has is that
audiences are stupid.
They're very, very smart.
They want to be challenged and
they want to go on a ride with you.
They don't want to be told everything.
Again, I took that and put it in here.
So all the things you're talking about.
I remember thinking, wow, I mean if,
if we could get away with all these subtle
hints that later you feel you earned
because you're like,
I did see that tiny thing in the first
act and it pay it off at the end.
That was great. I didn't want
to confuse anybody, but my,
my instinct was go with as little as
possible where people feel excited rather
than go with, okay guys, here's a
eight minute preamble of what happened.
This is a diagram of what everything looks
like and where they came from and all
that stuff. It was really fun to
have you be as an audience member,
as freaked out and nervous as to
what's going on is the family is
right. Yeah. The film doesn't really deal
with the backstory hardly at all. Um,
I did have one bone to pick,
which was comes the opening slate
and just says like, day 89. Yup.
It's like less than three months and
everything in the world has gone to shit.
Yup. Uh, they were quiet.
Not a lot of credit to give to humankind.
No less than three months.
But
it's funny, but you actually nailed
why I made it such a low day.
It's like it happened quickly
because, you know, for me,
alien movies are always about what
does the aliens, what do they want?
What's the grand plan? And I thought,
and I'm sure there, there has been, uh,
alien movies that are just about predators
or, or, or whatever. But my thing was,
what if these aliens just landed
and they don't want anything.
They just want to go for it,
you know?
And so it's like releasing wolves in a
daycare center. There's just no contest.
You know what I mean? So it was sort
of one of those things of like, Hey,
let's get into a war room and like, decide
what the, oh, everybody's gone. Yikes.
You know? So that's sort of what I thought
is what, that's, that's plausible too.
You know, everyone's like, did
he just say wolves in a, that,
that'll be played back. Perfect. That's
an interesting, uh, daycare center.
A very able bodied 30
year old. Sorry, sorry,
I did not mean the horrible
version that you thought. Um,
it's,
it's an interesting layer that I hadn't
considered the sort of how much we
flounder over choosing decisions and
making decisions in a moment like that
where I just didn't want
the president scene of like,
what do we do? Right, right.
Because the president was just,
you know,
people are just taking a different times
and so we talked about the parenting
layer, but it also, I was curious if
there's like a living in New York layer,
obviously, you know, you're
very well known actor,
creative person in the city is,
when did that thought ever cross your
mind when you were making this up?
Like having to navigate this city
without the massive monsters?
1000% yeah.
You're,
you're tapping into my secret idea of
how this would continue if it dig did
continue.
I think the idea of this whole world being
explored is really interesting to me.
Growing up in the east coast
and growing up in Boston,
I had to do it as rural northeast.
And the reason is not just
because I have a connection to it,
but also because I wanted
it to feel like anywhere,
anytime America that if this did happen,
that you could place yourself.
If you're from Indiana,
you can say like,
oh that sort of like a farm I grew up in.
It just places you in a,
I dunno when that way that sort of
nostalgic movies do really well close
encounters. I mean if you pulled
everybody here where that is, you know,
actually everybody here would
know because you're very smart.
But most people wouldn't remember.
They'd just say like, I dunno,
it's a guy who went crazy in the
middle of a mountainous area and I,
and I liked that. It's South
Dakota, isn't it? That you Googlers
nailed it.
Even the, uh, the smallness
of it as, as grandiose as the,
the environment, as grandiose as the
world is, the movie is very small.
It really the amount of time we're talking
about two days out of these people's
lives and, and the area that's
covered is a very small, um,
did you find that keeping it small
helped you connect with the core of the
family involved?
Oh, a thousand percent. Yeah.
I think that, you know, I'm,
I'm one of those people that the
more information you give me,
the more my mind wanders,
which makes me a very annoying person to
watch a movie because if you even drop
a hint at something, I'm like, hmm, what
happened to that? And people are like,
focus, there's a movie happening.
I'm like, man, I don't know this, uh,
this thing over here seems very untethered
to the rest of the movie. Um, but,
uh, but I think also this idea of family
was so much scarier because again,
you know, all the cliches
are true when you have kids,
but like your kids are the only
kids who exist in the world.
You know what I mean?
It's why every parent's like,
I think my kids really smart and you're
like, I think every kid is really smart.
Um, but it does, it feels very
intimate. It feels very much to you.
And I loved the idea that this family
just decided the priority number one was
this unit that it wasn't everybody
else. So yes, being on a farm,
the idea of isolation that visually not
being able to see other houses or see a
highway or a way out was really important
to me because they can't make it a
hundred yards, let alone a
hundred miles. I would want to,
I almost went into a spoiler do it,
but it's talk about the two kids. No,
a troop and Millicent seven
were great in the film.
How was it to work with them? Obviously
Noah has a huge reputation already.
Reputation.
He's got a reputation of,
it's like the kid in the back cause like
I do movies and Millicent up for a lot
of young acting awards. How was it
to work with the two of them? I mean,
here's the thing, they, you know, they,
I've always heard don't work with kids
because they slow everything down.
They never get the,
they never really understand what they're
saying and they don't get their takes.
Right. And they have kid hours, which
aren't the same full hours that you have.
And it just sounded like a nightmare.
I had the exact opposite experience.
So these kids are not only some of
the best actors I've ever worked with,
but some of the best people I've ever
gotten to know. That's the truth. I mean,
these kids are so unbelievably special
and you can see it in the movie.
And I remember Noah saying something
really interesting. He said, you know,
the lack of die, of course, he's more
articulate than me cause he's 13. Um,
but he said, uh, you know,
the lack of dialogue didn't
give me anywhere to hide
the fact that I didn't have
dialogue to hide behind. So what do you
mean by that? And he said, well, you know,
when you're rehearsing your lines,
you think of like timing and how you're
going to deliver it. And I was like,
obviously you're delivering it. Super
Cool. Um, and he said, you know,
when you don't have that,
you actually have to live through it.
You have to be sad, you have to
be scared, you have to be happy.
And I just said yes.
Just to all of that,
that you said sounds super
smart. Um, and uh, and it's true.
These kids were just so phenomenal.
I probably ended up slowing them down,
but how I found them was, you know,
Noah had been on the night manager,
which I saw and he was really great. And
I know this sounds horrible, but when I,
when I knew what I wanted for the movie,
I was watching him in the night manager.
I said, yeah, he's pretty good. And then
there's a scene where, sorry to spoil it.
Um, he gets kidnapped and I was like,
let's see how good he is with kidnapping.
And that kid does kidnap real
well. And I thought, well, he's in,
he's terrified and it looks,
I'm nervous to walk away and kidnapped
him and made him. Yes, that's right.
Not In the night manager, just
kidnapping, hired a couple of goons.
What am I talking about?
Are we in 1942. Um,
and then Millie was one of those things
where we just literally caught onto a
shooting star. I mean, she is,
it was nonnegotiable for me to have a
deaf actress in the movie, right? Um,
not for any grandiose PC reason,
but literally because obviously the,
the performance would be
much more textured, honest,
because she's living through it every
single day as, as a deaf person.
But more than that, I needed,
selfishly, I needed a guide.
I need someone to walk me
through this and I want,
I love collaborating and I love ideas.
And so I wanted her to come on set and I
wanted to know what it's like to be the
only deaf person in a hearing family.
What's it like? Do you get angry?
Do you get empowered?
What do you feel these things?
And she was so unbelievably
generous again, at the time,
I think she was 13 when we were shooting.
And Emily and I are convinced that
she's not actually from Earth,
that she's an angel. I mean, she's
the nicest, greatest human being.
And I know this sounds super poetic,
but it's true.
I've never had someone taking all of me
when they looked at me as I was talking,
she's looking at your hand gestures.
She's looking at your eyes and your,
your facial expressions.
But more than that,
she's legitimately feeling your essence.
She's a wonderfully powerful person.
I remember at south by southwest and my
mom went up to congratulate her and the
translator came over to help translate
for my mom or for Millie. And Millie said,
no, no, no, no. I know exactly what this
a woman is trying to say to me, which is,
it was just so beautiful.
So I mean,
I'll start crying right
now even thinking about it,
but it was so nice to have her on set.
And then to boot.
She's one of the best actresses
I've ever seen. I mean, even Emily,
who I think is the best actors going was
like, no, this girl is the real deal.
She's so phenomenal. So anyway, long,
I think that's the longest
answer I've ever given. Um,
were really fun to work with. Did you
know AFL before going into the film?
Did you have time?
I remember,
I think in like elementary
school in junior high school,
we learned some ASL. Um,
but no, the answer is no. I was, I was
aware of certain tiny bits and pieces.
We learned all the ASL for the scenes
and then we learned a little bit to
communicate more, you know, more, uh,
casually and comfortable
for Millie offset.
But then all of a sudden the crew
started learning ASL. Noah learned,
I think he might be fluent in ASL.
My biggest regret was not learning more
because I was so busy doing so many
different things that I wish I had
learned more because I know it's, again,
it sounds like I'm harping
on this romantic version,
but watching Millie talked to her mom,
I was convinced that there's no more
beautiful language in the world. I mean,
truly there's great languages to speak,
but watching someone paint their ideas
through the air is unlike anything I've
ever seen. And it plays
off really powerfully. Yes.
It works as a great boon for the
family in the film. Exactly. Yeah.
It's sort of the leg up that they have.
Yeah. Deeper level of communication.
We'll talk about working with Emily
in the, in the film she plays in.
Your white is only um,
yes, right. The diva. Um,
no, uh, Emily, they just cut you out.
John was all alone on that answer.
Um,
we've always wanted to work together.
We, we've always talked about it.
It's weird because we keep our
careers completely separate.
We never wanted the story of us being
married to supersede whatever story we
were telling on screen.
So it was hard to imagine that
we would be able to find it.
Luckily this story is pretty out
there, so we're safe. But on top of it,
it had to be an organic thing.
If I'm honest,
when I was doing the rewrite of the
script, I knew that I only wanted her.
She was very busy.
Like I said,
we had just had our second child and
she was also doing a little indie movie
called Mary Poppins. So,
um, she was working a lot.
Um, and, and to be honest,
I think I was just scared.
I think I was just
playing scared to ask her.
So the truth is I never even
brought it up to her. Um, it,
she knew what I was doing.
I pitched her ideas.
She started pitching other actresses
that she thought would be great for the
role.
And the reason why I didn't ask her it
was because I sought going one of two
ways. One, I asked her and she says, no,
which makes her a very awkward dinner.
Um, or she says, yes, I'll do it for
you. Which would honestly be worse.
That would be a heartbreak to me because
I've been witness to how intelligent,
how classy, the, the unbelievable
tastes level she has in her choices.
Um, I just couldn't stomach the idea
of her doing anything as a favor to me.
I had to let her career be her own.
So she read the script when we were flying
on a plane one day. She said, you know,
do you mind if I read it?
And I said, yeah, no problem.
Truly not thinking that she would do it.
And when she finished the script,
she turned to me and she
did look sick. Um, and I,
I literally went for like a
Barf bag and she said, you know,
you can't let anyone else play this
role. And I turned around, I said,
what are you saying? And she's like,
you can't let anyone else play it.
And it was like she was proposing to me,
are you saying what I think you're saying?
And she was like,
will you let me do the movie? And
I was like, yes. And I was like,
hold on. Sorry. I should have played
that so much cooler. Um, I dunno.
Let's see how you are on tape.
Um, what's set up an audition.
So I screamed yes, on an airplane and
then we were working together. So how,
how was it working with her? I
mean, the short answer is, um,
I finally got to see why
she's such a good actress.
I remember the week before
we started shooting,
I went to find an editing bay that
we would then edit the movie in.
And they actually happened to be editing
Mary Poppins at that editing bay.
And so rob Marshall, who's a unbelievable
human being in a wonderful director,
said, when are you shooting? And I
said, next week. And he said, Oh man,
you're going to see, I said, I know I love
her so much. And he said, no, no, no, no,
you're going to see. I said, I know
I'm her biggest fan. And he said, nope,
not until you're in the room
when she does what she does,
will you know why she's such a
good actress? And I thought, wow,
what an incredible thing to
say and also how dare you.
And um,
the scene that's in that poster was like
day three and he was absolutely right.
I mean, she did one take of that scene.
We have coverage of different shots,
but the, the big momentous moment of
the scene, um, she only did one take of,
and genuinely the air changed in the room.
I mean,
something came through the
room and I was totally stunned.
I couldn't say anything.
The crew couldn't say anything.
And then at the end of the take,
you literally hear me say,
that's lunch question mark.
Like, what do you do after that?
And this is how good my wife is.
She was like, yeah, by the way,
what do they have for
lunch? And I was like, what?
You were just like possessed by the devil
and now the devil is not in this movie.
I'm sorry, that was a miss
phrasing. That is a different movie.
This is just creatures,
just creatures.
Let's expand a little bit more on that.
While it's definitely production,
there's a,
I recognized very early and one of my
favorite parts of the production of the
film is the way that you deal with the
sound obviously sound is a huge part,
but the way it's dealt with,
uh, with Millie's character, uh,
the way that it's mixed throughout
the dynamic level. Yeah. How,
how far did you find yourself
wanting to push it? Uh, did you,
do you think you've got there?
Does it pay off for you as the director?
Yeah, I mean, it was really one of the
most fascinating parts of this experience.
I have always known the power of
sound because I did this movie with,
the first thing I ever did was I adapted
a script called brief interviews with
tedious men. That's David Foster
Wallace's book that I was in love with.
It's a very simple movie,
basically a woman interviewing
guys and I remember they said,
now you have to do your sound mix. And I
was like, cool, what does that, and um,
we went and mixed it and I realized
the power of even just dialogue scenes,
what happens when you sound mix, there's
a whole atmosphere and all these things.
So I learned very quickly,
little did I know how far you can go.
I mean truly through the
looking glass type stuff,
you can really lose your mind
in the sound design of this.
And I had the greatest people on board,
Ethan and Eric,
these guys are just so
unbelievably talented.
And they realized that this was such a
huge opportunity because in the movies
that we have nowadays, you're completely
surrounded by a wall of sound,
which can be a bit of an
assault on the senses.
And weirdly taking the sound
out is just as assaulting.
It's just as disconcerting.
And it was really,
really fun to start playing
with that and then realizing,
let's take a big swing
and see what happens.
And when you take certain
big swings, it's like, Whoa,
you really start pushing the boundaries
of certainly what I've experienced in
the movies before.
And that's been my favorite compliment
that audiences have been saying leaving
is that this is an experience.
It's not just the film.
I mean you can't get that without sort of,
you know,
assaulting the senses and all,
all ways. And so, yes, I think we,
I love what we did theirs.
There was always that happy medium of
making sure it didn't feel like a sound
experiment where people are
like, I get it, man. You,
you wanted to take us all the way and
you want people to remember that it is a
movie.
It has to be entertaining.
So just the idea of playing
with these things and,
and keeping it entertaining and
fun and moving was really good.
Important to me.
That's great.
How much more of this type of uh,
like all inclusive approach would you
like to take going forward from here?
Is it, is it a big challenge
to direct yourself, uh,
to get so involved in the production of
a movie and then be able to represent
the character as well? Yeah, it's so
weird because when you look at the
titles on paper, it seems
overwhelming. You immediately say,
what the hell are you doing? Why would
you do this on day one of shooting?
And you're like, why would you executive
produced help, right. Star and direct.
It sounds insane, but, and I, and I mean
this, it sounds super corny but it's true.
I've never been all in on a project
like this in my life. I mean this, yes,
it's really exciting for me as a director
and career wise it's something new and
different and I'm really excited about it.
But personally I was so emotional and so
emotionally connected to this material
because of the family and because of the
kids and because of thinking of my own
kids and things like that,
and having my wife onset that.
What you realize is those four titles
ended up being my only weapons to protect
the project in every facet. So it
became this unbelievable gift that yes,
it's a ton of work, but I loved it. How
much more would I do? I gotta be honest.
I love doing it. I love sort of developing
and producing and I'm sort of insane.
So I love sort of being crazy
with how much work is going on,
but I don't necessarily need to do
all of them all the time. You know,
maybe you direct and don't star. Maybe
you, you know, I'd also love to just act.
You know what I mean? That that's
also really fun for me. It's just,
I think I just love exploring is what it
is. That's the worst answer ever. Okay.
Have you ever,
I was to follow that up.
Have you found that the diversification
has helped you to transition out of what
was kind of a defining role for
you as Jim and the office? Yeah,
absolutely.
But
the truth is,
is it's funny,
I always want to make it clear that
I never wanted to diversify from Jim.
I think at the end of my career I'll
probably still be best known for that
character. And that is awesome.
I mean that's an honor. I mean,
you can't get a better thing than that.
That was so special.
It was lightening in a bottle.
And I remember till the
very last day of shooting,
it was lightening in a bottle.
We knew like I remember people coming
up who are on other TV shows being like,
what seasons did you guys start hating
each other? And I was like never.
I mean truly we were a
family till the very end.
So that was something that I actually
wanted to move and try other things
because I knew I could
never attain that again.
So it was trying to do different
things. And then the, the,
the truth is, and again,
it sounds Corny,
but I named my production company Sunday
night because when I first got to New
York, I was a waiter and a
bartender and whatever else,
weird job I could possibly find.
And I remember someone saying,
the one thing you don't get to
do as a working actor, his act,
you've got to do all these
other things to pay the bills.
So my friends and I would meet on
Sunday night and we're all trying to do
creative stuff.
And you realize it was the only night
that we could ever talk about plays,
movies, books, music.
And so we just nerded out on each other
and talked about all these huge dreams.
And if we got the chance, we do
this. And you know, the, these, uh,
these crazy Hollywood types don't know
how to do it. And, and it was so much fun.
Those people inspired my life forever.
So when I did get the opportunity,
like I said at the beginning,
when I did get the opportunity to
be in the office and have this huge
opportunity to have,
what do you want to do going forward?
I just thought of those guys and those
conversations than I thought I can't do.
I can't just sit back and wait for another
comedy or another show to come along
that's like that. I got
to try to, you know,
honor what we talked about at those
tables and, and that's why I did it.
That's why I started making different
choices and trying new things because I
thought these guys would 1000% do that
if they were given the same chance.
Excellent. Excellent. We do want
to open it up for questions.
If you guys want to make your way
to microphone over here a while,
they sort of get set and since
we're on the topic of the office,
Google here is a very big office really.
And
I was wondering in the time
where you're an office,
this looks like we're in Star Trek.
I feel like I'm,
I'm
[inaudible] up in space right now.
Right.
I was wondering in the time
since the show has ended,
if you've come up with
any great Jim pranks
that you would maybe go back and inactive
if you could know that we will take
your question over here. I
was never a prank. I, uh,
growing up, so I was so lucky.
The writers of the show were unbelievable.
I mean,
they've all gone on to create their
own hugely successful show so you can
genuinely see how talented they
were. But coming up, I mean,
it was my favorite thing to read those
scripts and be like, well, is he? Yes.
The like when you read the prank,
I think my favorite one was the nickels
and the receiver that was just so weird
and amazing and it took way too
much time and I loved all of it.
I love that. My favorite might've
been Asian jet. Yeah. Really good one.
Randall's amazing.
We'll take a question over.
Hello? Hello? Hey, I'm checking
the mic. That was a good idea.
Um,
I'm a big office fan and I'm really glad
that you decided to use fruit farms as
a set on your movie because
totally visualize that. Yeah.
Mom in Dwight to come out of the beat,
but as a director and a producer,
like what sort of decisions go into
choosing a set and choosing a location for
the film? I know you'd talked about city
versus rural, but even within rural,
you know, what kind of
decision making that you take?
Uh, a lot. It was really a,
so I started shooting the show Jack
Ryan and we were up in Montreal.
And so every, well, to be honest, every
day, but on the weekends especially,
I was looking at, this is not a joke,
I was looking on Zillow for like, uh,
farms in upstate New York because I
thought, well, if they're selling,
then maybe they'd like crazy
Hollywood to come in before they sell.
It turns out most people do not want that.
MMM.
And uh,
and I found this,
this house was on an old Zillow listing
and so I actually legitimately found the
house and then called the studio.
They send in someone to make sure that
people wouldn't fall into a sinkhole or
something when we were doing it. And, uh,
and then I met the guys
who were running it,
these two incredible farming farmers,
that family,
and they are the nicest people ever.
And I said, would you ever have a movie?
So then I flew down and
met them personally.
I had to do it all by myself
because I felt like if you're,
if you're going to completely
change their experience day to day,
you to have the personal connection of
letting them know that I'm here to do it,
not, you know, some group of 300 people.
So it was really fun to, to choose that.
So I had a lot to do with it
unfortunately. And so does Zillow,
I'm glad are also some crazy story
about growing a bunch of corn. Yeah.
So that farm, which you can't see, I
just pointed to nothing. So that farm,
uh, nowhere got it. Um,
it was a pumpkin farm and it
was something like 600 acres,
but they only used a certain amount of
acreage for Pumpkin's cause we were going
to be shooting in September or October
and they were the hottest Halloween,
Jabari and town. And so when I told them
that we needed corn, they were like, yeah,
yeah, sure. So some corn and
then we'll plan our pumpkins.
And I was like, no, no, no,
no guys, we're going to need
corn. And so they planted,
I mean something like 40
acres of corn or something.
And just as far as the eye could see.
And I will say the coolest thing is when
if finally cropped up when we started
shooting, the guys came and they looked
at it and they were like, this is awesome.
And I said, yeah, you're going to go back
to corn. They were like, God, no pumpkin.
So I was like, oh, okay. Great. Perfect.
That's the question from the side.
Hello.
A question about how you evaluate
like your career and your best work.
You've mentioned how important your
family is. Obviously in the industry,
there's people you idolize, that you've
gotten to meet. How'd you like evaluate?
Oh, that was, that was good work.
Or like the, the highlight. Yeah,
that's a really good question.
Um, if I'm really honest,
it's very difficult for me because I don't
know, just the way I grew up, it was,
I was never the, I
don't know, it was just,
I feel like it's something about Boston.
Boston was never one of those places
that you're like, I'm amazing.
And people are like, that's so great for
you. Usually you're like, I'm amazing.
And they're like, get them the one in
the back, take them out. Um, it was,
it's just a, it was a cool
place to grow up because you,
you got to focus on what you loved rather
than what you loved about yourself.
And so, um, it's really hard
for me to be like, it's amazing.
I think that in a terrible baseball
analogy, here it comes. Um,
it's that idea of like when you
hit the fat of the bat, you know,
when the ball connected in a way you
don't know what's going to happen to that
ball. But you know, you felt
really good about what happened,
told you it was a terrible,
there's a part of the bat that's fatter.
It doesn't matter. I blew
it. Basically. I can tell,
I can tell when I'm happy
with what what I did. And um,
I know when we were shooting this that
something felt very special for me.
And to be honest,
the most overwhelming thing about the
very kind response that this movie's
gotten is goes back to instinctual
high school days of like,
you have something that you think is cool
and you really hope that other people
think it's cool too. And when other
people go, yeah, that's cool. You're like,
oh my God. I mean it's
genuinely moving. I mean,
when we were at south by
southwest the night before,
we premiered down there and my wife said,
you know what's,
what's the one thing you
want to take away from this?
Just so you're not stressed about the
whole thing. And I was like too late. Um,
and I said, you know, if, if
people cheered at the end,
that would be really cool cause it's
a kind of a fun experience. And uh,
when people jumped out of their chairs
and screamed at the top of their lungs,
I think I blacked out and only
woke up yesterday like I was,
I am so genuinely moved and
overwhelmed by that response.
So I can say I'm happy by the response,
but I'm not like, I'm awesome.
I'm pretty awesome.
If that was terrible, people
are like an record that. Thanks.
Um, so one thing, I've only seen
the trailer so far and I can't wait.
See the movie.
Maybe it will be addressed,
but you had 89 days to take the
batteries out of that space shuttle.
What was going on there? All
right man. Turn off the cameras.
Turn on
the cameras. Um, uh, what
you'll see in the movie is,
um, when you are putting a
situation and they're coming,
these creatures are coming. This is
just a parable guys. Um, no, the,
it's everything is very
specific to survival. So, uh,
you'll see in the movie that that space
shuttle is not something that is theirs.
They do not own that. So the, they,
there was no way for them to know that
batteries were in the space shuttle
because they didn't know it existed. And
I'm not going to spoil it, but it had,
I known the batteries were in it, I
probably would've done something about it.
Okay.
We only have time for a couple more,
so we'll if we can wrap and
fire maybe two on this side,
two on this side and you
can at the same time. No,
Dwight. Uh, go ahead. Hi. First of all,
thank you for coming. Oh my God, this
is so exciting. Thanks. Um, I have, uh,
basically pop of the paper,
a basic question,
but did you have any like favorite
scene from the office that you like to
Rewatch or anything?
Um, I rewatch everything all the time.
No. Going back to the other question,
I don't,
I,
I think one of my favorite scenes
there are two that I always remember.
I don't watch them over and over
cause I just play it in my head.
Two things really specific moment was
when Steve had us over to his apartment
and he took the TV and he said, and
then when guests, guests come over,
you can just do that. I think that's the
hardest I've ever laughed in my life.
And then the other one is when he
dressed up as Santa and had, uh,
Kevin sit on his lap.
I mean if you watch the outtakes,
I would very clearly it was unprofessional
person because I couldn't get through
that scene. So those are the two that
I play back in my head and laugh.
Thank you. Cook one. Hold on a sec.
Oh Hey John. Hey Horan good. Um,
I didn't know that this movie was about
protecting your children and that's
really cool cause I'm having my first
son when my first child in August.
Congratulations. Thank
you. That's awesome.
So now I want to see it and
I'm going to be my way. Um,
tell her it is way easier to
give birth and this I promise.
All right. She won't believe you,
but, um, I really want to know,
I'm getting advice from like everybody
and their mother and her landscaper for
parenting, but yeah. Cool. They
get parenting advice from you.
Oh, that's really, um,
and protecting from aliens and,
yeah. Yeah. So when aliens come,
you're gonna want to clear out all
the noisy toys. Take those away.
Anything plushes safe?
Um, no, it's funny. I,
my number one bit of parenting advice
has been listened to no one because it's
always a unique experience, but
to me that, to walk away, um,
no, I, I got so many different
pieces of advice that I,
I still to this day use one of which
is, uh, communicate with your kids.
Don't just talk to them and
tell them what's happening.
You actually have to walk them through
it because they see things in extremes.
So, you know, instead of saying, you know,
don't hit your sister and we're going
to put you in a timeout or something.
It's like, Hey, so I've asked you three
times not to hit your sister in the face,
and now we're going to go over here and
you have to step away from the game.
And they actually process really,
really well.
And I think that that's a big
misconception certainly of mine,
was that they can't process,
there's so much smarter than you are,
and I know you work at Google, but
trust me, this kid isn't even out yet,
and he's smarter than
you. Yeah, you got it.
That seems like a pretty great place to
wrap up on the front. You've got, yeah.
I want to thank you for,
thank you very much.
[inaudible].